[Música]
qué tal me da mucho gusto darles soy
miguel ángel osorio chong soy de hidalgo
y me da mucho gusto participar hoy por
primera vez una práctica de el poder
hablar de mis orígenes o poder hablar de
mi persona de lo que he sido en función
de lo que me gusta
con lo que crecí que fue en la política
que servir a los demás es procurar una
mejor circunstancia para las celos
mexicanas y mexicanos a los que servimos
pero hoy particularmente
quise que me permitieran hablar del tema
de la igualdad de género un tema
fundamental para nuestra sociedad para
el crecimiento de nuestra sociedad miran
porque un político habla de igualdad
porque el sistema fundamental hoy por el
que debemos de tener toda la atención y
toda la preocupación yo nací cuando por
segunda ocasión se le permitía el voto a
la mujer para definir la presidencia de
la república y también nací en una
generación en el que todo se refería a
apoyar a respaldar a los varones en el
que se le daban todas las
responsabilidades a los hombres incluso
desde sentarnos la cabecera en el quién
iba a la escuela
y esto provocó que hoy estamos en una
circunstancia difícil compleja en una
circunstancia en la que no queremos ni
para nuestras hijas ni para nuestras
mamás ni para nuestras parejas lo que
queremos es construir una mejor sociedad
y eso pasa por el involucramiento de
todos
imagínense 7 de cada 10 mujeres sufren
algún tipo de violencia yo creo que
muchas más porque muchas ni siquiera van
y hacen su denuncia por miedo por terror
imagínese usted es en el mercado laboral
por las mismas labores de un hombre las
mismas responsabilidades
les pagan
16 puntos menos en su salario de cada
100 pesos la mujer sólo recibe 85 por lo
mismo
lo que sufren las calles los piropos que
se quedan graciosos los hombres cuando
le causan terror que les causan
verdaderamente preocupación a las
mujeres
siete de cada diez mujeres han sido
violentadas como se los decía y muchas
de esas violencias llegan a feminicidios
llegan a eso que hoy ésta ha crecido en
los últimos dos años 7% las llamadas de
auxilio durante la pandemia crecieron
50% que quiere decir que la violencia
inicia en los hogares ahí en el que el
macho lástima verbal
emocionalmente
económicamente o pues quitándole la vida
a una mujer luego otro tema fundamental
pues resulta que la insensibilidad de
los funcionarios que deben de atender
esta problemática pues se ve a diario
regresa después un hombre de si no te
maltrato tanto a uno no te preocupes
mira vamos a hacer un convenio para que
te pida perdón qué pasa después son más
violentos
y por supuesto acaban lastimando a las
mujeres eso es lo que ya no tenemos que
permitir tenemos que avanzar como
sociedad se avanza el tema de la
igualdad no va en detrimento del hombre
del varón en favor de la sociedad se
avanza una mujer avanzamos todos por eso
es tan importante el tema que hemos
hecho tuve la fortuna de ser gobernador
de mi estado soy de hidalgo y ahí
trabajamos mucho para poder
evolucionar en el respaldo a la mujer
qué quiere decir esto bueno abrir las
nuevas brechas abrirles más pasos de
participación y no sólo en lo político
sino en el mercado laboral sino en hacer
ciudades seguras esto también lo vi ya
después como secreto de gobernación
ciudades seguras que lo hacíamos con la
onu la onu que está muy interesado en el
tema bueno pues por donde caminan las
mujeres por dónde van a prepararse a
estudiar por donde pues nunca se pensó
en ellas y entonces todo está ya hecho
preparado para los varones y para los
varones les hacen calles muy angostas en
el que entonces se pueden encontrar con
violentos
obscuras
el transporte público no llega a todas
las colonias y luego bueno llegan al
lugar donde trabajan o donde estudian y
pues va más allá de un bullying es el
ataque que se le hace a las mujeres por
eso es que siempre están todas en una
convocatoria una convocatoria
haciendo bueno lo que nos corresponde
porque pues es bien fácil en un discurso
decir está está en preocupación este
tema no tenemos que reaccionar tenemos
que hacer algo cuando fui gobernador
entonces abrí muchas oportunidades en mi
estado no solamente insisto en los
espacios de labor de la responsabilidad
pública sino después lo que traté de
hacer es que fuera el empoderamiento de
la mujer
que es el empoderamiento de la mujer que
puedan salir adelante solas sin
necesidad de que tengan que depender del
varón y en eso es algo a lo que los
hombres de luego no permiten porque me
quite espacio porque eso sólo para los
hombres porque la mujer no no puede con
esa responsabilidad no pueden mucho más
ellas no no pueden igual son superiores
a nosotros pero no se trata de ver quién
puede más sino de hacer una sociedad en
igualdad de oportunidades y por eso es
que bueno lo hice en el gobierno y luego
como secreta de gobernación junto con
los gobiernos estatales los locales los
municipales empezamos a hacer acciones
miren por ejemplo hicimos había 10
centros de justicia
ahora hay uno por estado por lo menos
son 36 que son estos lugares pero
primero el lugar donde acude una mujer
que es violentada pero pues antes nada
más había refugios que bueno por cierto
hoy ya les quitaron el respaldo el apoyo
donde acudían por miedo porque las
acaban de golpear a esconderse en estos
centros de justicia lo que hacen es
apoyarlas para su defensa para
protegerlas pero además para prepararlas
para que si ellas deciden no tienen que
regresar al hogar donde les lastiman
donde les pegan donde les cometen todo
tipo de injusticias se les capacita de
tal manera que puedan entrar al mercado
laboral puedan salir adelante se les
prepara se les da instrucción escolar a
que no la tiene o a quien la necesita o
la que la quiere el son los centros de
justicia eso es trabajar por las mujeres
si hemos avanzado también en play es en
el empoderamiento en temas de
responsabilidad pública para que haya
igualdad
en las responsabilidades que hay en el
nivel municipal estatal y federal pero
yo digo que eso no es todo tenemos que
cambiar desde acá tenemos que hacer que
cambien esos estereotipos machistas que
se siguen sufriendo en muchos hogares
millones de hogares de méxico cuando les
digo que subió un 50 por ciento el
número d
peticiones de auxilio pues debe ser una
preocupación enorme en pandemia pero hoy
en el año 21 seguimos con un 46 por
ciento arriba de llamadas de auxilio y
que creen que pasa después pues pasa que
se les lástima y pasa que las someten y
pasa que entonces las dificultades son
enormes para ellas desde todas las
edades esto hay que decirlo bien claro
no solamente a las crías son mayores no
de todas las edades por eso es
importante entonces que todos como
sociedad juntos mujeres y hombres
vayamos a señalar a quien maltrata a las
mujeres a no dejarnos que no conoce una
mujer que la han maltratado que no
conoce a un hombre que hasta festeja
lastimar a una mujer eso no lo podemos
seguir permitiendo por eso es tan
importante que podamos unirnos que
podamos entonces emprender un trabajo
conjunto
en el que desde el hogar se procure en
igualdad de circunstancia a la niña que
al niño que se le procure entonces
después en la escuela darles igual
participación
cuántos de nosotros nos fuimos a
estudiar y sólo había un 30% de mujeres
en nuestras oficinas no había más que un
10% hoy han cambiado las cosas pero no
lo suficiente todavía está muy complejo
muy difícil y por eso es que tenemos que
avanzar pero más deprisa este si es una
prioridad las mejores naciones las que
están más evolucionadas las que tienen
mejores condiciones
de oportunidades para la sociedad son
naciones en donde existe verdaderamente
igualdad donde hay igualdad de
oportunidades
para prepararse y luego en el sector
laboral de verdad hay que reconocerles
hacer naciones tenemos que avanzar en
nuestro país
y además algo importante tenemos que
actuar de diferente manera no es lo
mismo la violencia que se sufre en el
sector rural que en el urbano iguales en
sus circunstancias finales sí pero
tenemos que atacarlo de diferente manera
y no debe ser un pretexto la situación
económica eso no viene nací en un hogar
en el que el estereotipo así era en la
sociedad lo que quiero decirles que en
mi casa llevaba trabajada mi hermana
trabajaba y estudiaba igualdad de
oportunidades todos le entrábamos
por eso es que sé de lo que hablo cuando
escucho un nombre que dice yo ayudo a mi
esposa o ayuda a mi mamá en las labores
de
del hogar no no no no no
asumimos la misma responsabilidad que es
diferente no es sólo dejar la tarea a
las mujeres las mujeres hacen trabajo en
el hogar van con toda la responsabilidad
de la familia además salen a trabajar
salen y se preparan y además descargamos
toda la culpa eso no puede seguir
sucediendo tenemos que asumir otro rol
otra circunstancia para las mujeres hay
muchos grupos que en los estados están
participando pero insisto no es
suficiente tenemos que hacer más tenemos
que meternos más y yo sé que hay miles y
millones de hombres que si lo quieren
porque asumen que no solamente es un
tema de romanticismo es un tema de
responsabilidad
todos tenemos la mà todos tenemos
hermanas todos tenemos una mujer
alrededor y somos parte también de
alrededor de uno de una mujer por eso
tenemos que estar en la igualdad y por
eso tenemos que trabajar conjuntamente
y creo que es el momento es el momento
para méxico le llegó el momento a mexico
no podemos seguir dejando que
diariamente 10 mujeres pierdan la vida
solo y simplemente por el hecho de que
son mujeres
no podemos seguir lo permitido 10 al día
con esta tierra a mi si mucho por eso es
que creo que es fundamental que nos
pongamos a trabajar las condiciones a
veces pareciera que no son las óptimas
no les quitaron por ejemplo los recursos
a las instancias infantiles que eran las
ciudades infantiles donde las mujeres
dejaban a sus hijos en confianza con un
vecino o una vecina iban a ser bien
cuidados y ya podía salir a trabajar oa
prepararse bueno pues hoy
parece que retrocedemos en ese tema pero
no podemos quedarnos con los brazos
cruzados tenemos que hacer mucho más
tenemos que asumir nuestra
responsabilidad
hago un llamado a todas ya todos sobre
todo a los varones a que pasemos de
ser solamente quienes ven datos y cifras
de lo que les pasa a las mujeres a
asumirnos con una responsabilidad de
trabajar para que deje de pasar está en
nuestras manos es desde los hogares es
en la calle es donde se preparan o donde
trabajan es en todos lados si cada quien
ponemos lo que nos toca entonces las
cosas van a cambiar porque si no lo
hacemos entonces las nuevas generaciones
van a ser lo mismo y entonces lo van a
replicar y lo van a multiplicar un niño
que ve que su papá maltrata a su esposa
pues lo único que va a hacer cuando
crezca es hacer exactamente lo mismo
porque va a resultar común fácil eso no
lo podemos seguir permitiendo
no solamente el castigo a los
infractores no es solamente el castigo a
los violentos va más allá de eso
también una nueva educación que permita
que entonces se cambien estas
circunstancias adversa para las mujeres
no puede ser solamente nuestro cariño
nuestro amor a las mujeres tienen que
ser acciones responsables y en eso
nosotros tenemos un gran compromiso un
gran gusto saludarles o jalarse de
muchas oportunidades de estas pláticas
estas charlas ted me parecen muy
interesantes muy importantes y estoy a
solas muchas gracias